I'm about to change your life because
this piece of research changed mine
I'm gonna give you three ways on how I
avoid procrastination hopefully that
helps you to rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
deal with procrastination over to you
Mel Robbins I'm about to change your
life because this piece of research
changed mine procrastination has nothing
to do with work
the people that write to us the most
that struggle with procrastinating PhD
students engineers entrepreneurs people
that have a lot on their plate that have
a lot of things that they need to juggle
and that are analytical and thinkers by
nature procrastination is a form of
stress relief
what are you stressed about
bingo and it makes you upset doesn't it
yeah how many of you can relate to that
she said that what's stressing her out
is she wants to retire she hasn't saved
up enough money what's really stressing
you out is finances and money and the
fear that you have what happens when you
struggle with procrastinating and thank
you for being so honest there's it
stresses you out maybe you feel the same
way and we felt that way I know exactly
what you're talking about
you carry around this dark cloud because
you don't think you're gonna make it
you're stressed about money all the time
or maybe your mom's health is declining
and it really stresses you out or maybe
your best friends are going through a
divorce or you're going through a
divorce and that really stresses you out
and so you walk around with this big-ass
thing on your shoulders all the time and
then you walk into work and you sit down
and you've got a list of phone calls to
make which requires your prefrontal
cortex and your prefrontal cortex looks
at the list and it's like oh my god you
want me to make 15 phone calls I've been
worried about the money all day can we
just look at cat videos I need a break
and next thing you know two hours is
gone you've been online shopping even
looking at cat videos and then of course
you look at the 15 phone calls you're
like I didn't make him I didn't make him
I didn't make the research on
procrastination is undeniable it's black
and white
number one all of you that procrastinate
procrastination is not the issue it's
stress you're procrastinating to give
yourself a little break at work it's
sort of like taking a smoking break
almost you know you're just taking a
break so number one because you're all
stressed out and for cras inators are
very hard on yourselves this is gonna
sound super stupid but you got to
forgive yourself you have got to
actually have a talk with yourself where
were you feel yourself starting to
procrastinate you go look you know I
really screwed up I know I'm in a mess
financially I forgive myself I'm just
gonna do the best that I can so you have
to address the thing that's underneath
it so that's self-awareness of knowing
oh my god here's that stress again about
finances screwing me over and preventing
me from doing the small things that will
act
fix my finances second thing that you're
gonna do procrastinations a habit right
you get triggered by stress the habit is
to procrastinate so when you get
triggered by stress your new habit is oh
there's my stress again I'm gonna
actually tell myself okay you've done
the best you can it's okay we're gonna
do a little bit today you're gonna
create what we call starting ritual a
starting ritual is something that pushes
you to start the best one on the planet
the five-second rule so you've said okay
there's my stress again I forget myself
now we're gonna 5 4 3 2 1 I want you to
only work for 5 minutes that's it five
minutes make phone calls for five
minutes here's what we know based on the
research 80% of you will keep going the
trick is starting you see I want to
break the connection between the trigger
which is stress and the response which
is procrastination and whenever you feel
stressed which is normal you have a
choice here's that gap in 5 seconds flat
the habit of procrastinating and beating
yourself up will take over or you can
close the gap 5 4 3 2 1 and you can make
a different choice I'm just gonna get
started I'm just gonna be okay with
where I'm at and I'm just gonna get
started got it good so I've seen this
clip a few times and it's starting to
sink in for me I love Mels perspective
on it I just like how she's coming from
a different place the idea that
procrastination is really coming from a
place of stress I don't have fully
formed thought surrounding yet I won't
share that with you but I encourage you
to think about if you are delaying
something in your life what are you
stressed about and can you change that
to help you get going
the thing that Mel really stresses is
around how to change yourself in the
moment how to change your mindset how to
reshift and use the five-second going to
get back into it what I want to focus on
today is talking about how can you use
systems to get your procrastination
levels down so that you don't have to
rely on being in the moment I think when
you try to do things in the moment a lot
of times you'll let yourself down you
may know of something like the
five-second rule but you forget to do it
you get overwhelmed and you forget to do
it and so for me what I prefer doing is
instead of trying to rely remembering
something in the moment to set up my
life my schedule my business so that it
defaults me to plain the way that I want
to play I'm gonna give you three ways on
how I avoid procrastination hopefully
that helps you to number one is bat your
days
every day the week is different from me
but every Monday is the same and every
Tuesday is the same everyone's it's the
same so if I'm making YouTube videos on
a Tuesday I have to make a lot of videos
you know if I don't get these videos
done for you it means videos will not go
live from my channel I don't remember
the last time we have not had a video go
live on a channel for a day it's been a
long long long long time and so because
I have so much that I have to get done
in that day it beats me out of
procrastination I have no choice but to
get up and do it otherwise there's just
so much pain in that I will have no
videos on the channel for that week
because Wednesday I'm doing something
else
I can't let Tuesday bleed into Wednesday
because Wednesday I have a whole bunch
of other stuff that need to get done and
Thursday I'm in meetings all day long
and so there's no buffer time I need to
get that work done on Tuesday so I
designed my schedule to allow me to be
productive I don't have the option
procrastinate because there's no other
day to do it where if you say I'll get
this done tomorrow and that can lead to
the next day and that can eat to the
next day you allow yourself that buffer
and so you will often take that buffer
whenever you give it to yourself so it's
much more about designing your schedule
with intent and purpose once instead of
relying on having the awareness to say
I'm progressing it again and using a
rule to help you get there
number two is commit to somebody else if
you know that this is a problem for you
commit to somebody else that you're
gonna be there at a certain time this is
an issue that Alex and I face with
Toronto dine salsa he would have a hard
time getting started in the morning for
me I don't care about what hours people
are working what time a day they're
working doesn't make a difference as
long as the work is getting done
he was not used to that kind of freedom
at the beginning and so he would sleep
in who procrastinate until I absolutely
had to get done there's so much pressure
that he had to get it done so to be more
proactive he said to me hey I'm gonna
show up at your place and we're gonna
work together at this time so every day
he's got to show up by this time and
he's got to be ten minutes early and if
he's not I give him crap for it and he's
rushing in the morning to make that
happen because he's committed to me to
be there and so if you commit to
somebody else they're much more likely
to follow through and that sets you up
for the rest of the day so if you have a
hard time getting started in the morning
have your first thing be committing to
somebody else to show up and be there so
that you will actually do it you let
yourself down all day long but you don't
want to let other people down so you
will show up commit to other people and
number three is change your environment
I walk into this I
into this to get me inspired on a daily
basis I see some of my heroes on the
wall behind me I read a page from my
book the top ten rooms a success every
day watching the videos on my channel
every day and preparing content and so
that environment that I create for
myself on a daily basis sets me up so
again I don't need to come in and think
about how am I gonna be inspired today
how am I gonna motivate today trying to
catch myself when I'm falling down I
think we play small by default all day
long and we never catch it and so you
might catch it 3% of the time and great
you can use tactics for that but I'm
talking about the 97% of the other time
where you play small and don't even
realize it and you're giving yourself
excuses for why you're doing it and so
if you can elevate your environment from
the physical environment to the habits
to the routines to what you're consuming
doing that on a regular basis raises
your level if you are around people who
are not procrastinating you won't
procrastinate either and being around
people could be here I'm around these
people I'm around the people in the book
I'm around the people who I'm watching
videos up I'm around them and the more
I'm around those people the less I'm
gonna procrastinate too now I've got a
really special bonus clip that I want to
share with you but before that question
today I want to know how do you deal
with procrastination what's your go-to
strategy please share down the comments
below it might really help some of the
members of believe nation so put it in
the comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
expresso give me
most people procrastinate because they
don't feel confident that the what
they're doing really motivates them if
you're really motivate motivated you it
what you wouldn't procrastinate it's
like a 14 year old kid that the mom and
dad can't get the kid to do anything but
the kids motivated play video games
Kittel ride his bike across town to buy
a video game and come back like so
there's motivation there the parents
just don't know how to find it and as
you grow you have to know how to find
deep within yourself that motivation and
once you have motivation you have no
problem with procrastination our world
today with its amazing technological
advances and the fact that this
innovation cycle is ever shortening this
world has no space for those who
procrastinate
it's that urgency that makes me say to
colleagues of mine in the company but if
you have good news for me take the
stairs but if you have bad news take the
elevator I need to know that quickly so
I can do something about it a lot of
people think that urgency and patience
are contradictory and they could not be
more wrong you need to be patient enough
to listen to everybody but yes you must
have a sense of urgency to take a
decision and to execute if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe it act
like I tell so what a whale out of
handcuffed lightning throw thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 four days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 250 four days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access